the bootleg capture 40.3
yo-ho his power 98.3 the bootleg catch
so we broadcasting live from the 2012
MTV VMAs and right now in front of me we
got one of the hottest rappers on the
planet his name he SAP rocky what's up
bro what's up brah how you doing I'm
high I'm chillin man I'm just trying to
you know stay away well you know what
now you can hear me it's two separate
mics keep it on keep those ones are we
good all right there we go
yeah I know I wanted to ask you um you
just dropped the ASAP mob mixtape yep
which is dope lords never worry how's
the reception been on that joint man um
I've been getting a lot of love for it
but I really wasn't too pleased the way
it came out I didn't have enough time to
sit on it actually it was mostly me Ames
who you know executive produced it but
you know I didn't have a lot of time to
really make the proper changes that I
wanted it's an internal thing I'm a
perfectionist I guess and you know you
I'm my own worst critic but for the most
part I think it came out we had some
good content on it and I think you know
people needed to see what we were
capable of what weren't you happy about
you know with the release because man
you know I would have I would have I
would have had skits in there yeah I'd
have had you know how did we have time
week is it's because in the process of
making that album we had the people
waiting for so long there's a long wait
man that it's like if we would it right
now I would still be working on it you
know how pissed people will be with me
right now your fans are crazy broke man
they've been waiting they would be
pissed man but that long live ASAP is
about to be epic yeah it's a little
first debut album yes long live ASAP man
yes of course this is this is like your
first look and I always feel like that
debut albums got to be something special
yep and I know you've been keeping
everybody waiting you know what is the D
of course I know you got a date for the
album you gotta have a date Halloween
baby Halloween yes that's a beautiful
thing yes sir is that if you think
that's a mistake
I mean you know how it is he's gonna
stick this is Halloween it's Halloween
yeah that's the perfect date I am this
your first VMAs bro
yeah man so what I mean well that's far
who are you looking forward to seeing I
mean have you been starstruck yet
walking around hell no it's like now I'm
in the studio with Kanye y'all keep it
in a Hyundai it's like I'm too cool to
be starstruck like I'm just too high to
be starstruck but like I'm always hot
bro
to be fair man you're a young kid who
you know a year and a half ago is
chilling in Harlem with your boys you
know what I'm saying and it's just so
crazy to see the growth because I
remember the first time I saw purple
swag yeah and now you're that dude and
like like now you know you're at the
VMAs man you ever like sit back and
recollect on that kind of stuff I can
imagine that'd be kind of crazy to just
kind of think about like a year I tried
some with the homies just right not to
because maybe it'll make me feel lazy or
maybe it is it has scared me I try not
to think about it I just go with the
flow cuz I'm not scared and that's a
that's abnormal like yeah you know most
people did petrified but I feel like I
was not only do I feel like I was born
for this but I really don't recollect
all dwell on old stuff that I did and
you know I just look forward to really
being accomplished and I just want to
really just finish branding what I'm
trying to show people what we're about
and then I could sit back and be like
man we did it yeah you are on the new
remix with Rihanna the cockiness right
that man how'd you like that man I
actually liked him is I'm not mad about
it as he was a lot of people don't like
a lot of people didn't expect to like it
they like I actually like did you get
some some negative feedback from your
core fanbase no cuz I know sometimes you
know that's what I'm saying anytime I
collab with anybody mainstream my core
fan base attack see this time they did
it this time they was witty like yo and
Rihanna approached you to get on the
record yeah yes she hit us up and I got
only a step it was an honor to work work
you guys get to smoke some nice not yet
though it's coming yeah man we probably
smoked some she seemed like a cool chick
yeah yeah for sure and I know you just
grabbed a couple magnums Oh next to it a
lot of
so hopefully hahaha Rihanna likes to get
it in you don't say hey I don't know
about that I got a girlfriend now
Oh Peggy the girlfriends oh I know
that's out there but I yeah okay we're
gonna keep it moving on that one it's
all good al before I let you go we do a
feature called the 6:28 hate uh-huh and
what it is is pretty much listeners
calling and they hate on anything
whether it be like dudes wearing you
know capris order or Mitt Romney okay
what is something you want to hate on
ASAP rocky for real for real
I hate tacky [__] man straight
up that was tacky to you oh man these
dudes with no [__] I'm pardon my
language okay cuz like a [__]
like they have like no fashion etiquette
at all is this they just I'm just
talking about normal rappers we think
big chains on and just compensating for
the lack of you know fashion sense like
I don't know I just tacky [__]
you know when you see them like the
[__] with the what with the
Gucci on and and I feel you geez all
over it and the clear Nike Air Force
Ones yep spongebob Jordans I'm mad at
you RAF we gonna let you get out of here
before B ah to kiss my ass my brother's
nice be nice peace